Isabella Velásquez: Thank you Rachel hi everybody so nice to be here and to chat with you about building a blog that are,
Isabella Velásquez: A little bit about me and I have the great pleasure of working at RStudio with Rachel and many others,
Isabella Velásquez: And I am the senior product marketing manager and currently I focus on the strategy and the content creation for the RStudio blog,
Isabella Velásquez: it's been an amazing almost five months and again it's just been amazing to have the opportunity to work with others in RStudio and others in the data science community,
Isabella Velásquez: and as such I would love to hear your compelling data science stories and if you're ever interested in collaborating on post on our seo blog please consider this an open invitation,
Isabella Velásquez: To reach out to me,
Isabella Velásquez: We can brainstorm we can collaborate if you're already thinking about something in particular so again really excited to,
Isabella Velásquez: To communicate with you and then also chat about how to create your own blogs,
Isabella Velásquez: And so just a little bit more about me and my free time i'm also very active in the art Community i'm a proud of our lady Seattle co organizer and sometimes I post on my personal blog as well, and so my very first ladies talk was actually on the blog,
Isabella Velásquez: package right back in 2018 funnily enough so i'm really excited so many years later it's your continue talking about building the blog with R,
Isabella Velásquez: And so, just a quick intro question, if you have any data science or technical blogs that you love to read, please put them in the chat and feel free to share why you love them so much,
Isabella Velásquez: So today's agenda that will be going through our possible reasons for creating a blog that sort of topics and,
Isabella Velásquez: That you might like want to consider and other things that you want to take note of before building your blog and then of course the actual tools for building your blog with R,
Isabella Velásquez: And I have a lot of resources in this repository so that they are easy to find, as well as the slides that you see here, so if you have any questions like Rachel mentioned, please put them in psycho or in the chat as we can discuss them at the end of today's presentation,
Isabella Velásquez: And so well today's talk title is building a blog with R we're actually going to be talking about websites a little bit more generally,
Isabella Velásquez: So a blog is a very specific type of website that has a reverse chronological order, where the your content appears first, and it can allow for things like comments and can be syndicated on rss feeds index, etc,
Isabella Velásquez: And some website pages can be quite static and they're not updated very frequently, whereas a blog tends to be very dynamic, you want to keep it fresh content,
Isabella Velásquez: And there are also other sorts of websites that support dialogue and conserve a sort of libraries of knowledge,
Isabella Velásquez: Such as wikis or forums, but blogs specifically add this kind of time factor to consider them successful we want continuous engagement continuous content,
Isabella Velásquez: And the type of content considered for a blog it's different to it can be more real time to things like events that are happening and more of an opinion, rather than a reference and we'll get into that as well later,
Isabella Velásquez: And so, just to reiterate, I will are talking about blogs specifically know that art and actually be used to create these other types of websites as well,
Isabella Velásquez: And so we should talk about why create a blog in the first place, and I would like to clean,
Isabella Velásquez: Apologies is kind of,
Isabella Velásquez: Okay, so i'd like to glean some insights that i've seen from other people's talks,
Isabella Velásquez: David Robinson ones bro if you've given advice three times, then it's time to consider giving a blog,
Isabella Velásquez: On the resources page that I shared with you, I actually created a YouTube playlist in case he wants to see a talks from allison hill vicki boykins,
Isabella Velásquez: mile selman this one from David Robinson if you'd like to hear their insights as well, but in terms of like sharing a blog there are various different things that come to mind so,
Isabella Velásquez: Being able to share your opinions and what you learned if there's a package you've investigated for a particular project or something that sort of workflow or process that you went through and you want others to learn about,
Isabella Velásquez: Like I mentioned earlier blogs are also an opportunity to write about your own opinions and kind of share the insight that you've gleaned from your expertise and your experience and,
Isabella Velásquez: If you care to do so, you can also get feedback, in the form of comments or social media discussions and things like that,
Isabella Velásquez: And then also to give updates news and let other folks know what is going on in the world,
Isabella Velásquez: But thinking about a data science Community specifically as blogs can really help showcase the kind of soft skills needed for data scientists, they can provide a platform to share,
Isabella Velásquez: It allows you to practice writing for someone other than yourself, it can form a sort of portfolio of work and makes it very easy to share, because everything is in one place and in a kind of centralized is your work, rather than having things in various different spots,
Isabella Velásquez: And so, when you watch us talks and we're generally We often talk about reasons behind creating a personal blog, especially if you're looking for a job,
Isabella Velásquez: But I also want to note that your team or organization could also benefit from having a blog so external blogs, like the ones that we have at RStudio, for example, these,
Isabella Velásquez: Quick aside, just so you're aware, we have four different blogs RStudio bond, which is the one that I helped manage the Ai blog which has the latest news of Ai technologies and his website is actually still that we're going to be talking about later, one of the tools for creating blogs,
Isabella Velásquez: And then the our views blog which is present stories from the our Community and is actually built with lockdown the other tool that will be talking about later,
Isabella Velásquez: And then the tidy verse blog which uses he goes down which focuses on just he, though,
Isabella Velásquez: Whereas the other package that I mentioned blog down actually let's see us other kinds of static web site generators, and so I just wanted to quickly share that RStudio actually uses our in many different ways to build our blogs,
Isabella Velásquez: And so, our blogs help keep the Community up to date with events and products, just to show a few different examples,
Isabella Velásquez: Here is one showcasing the Community events like this one today and just letting folks know in terms of what is happening, this month, what happened last month and where to find different sorts of resources,
Isabella Velásquez: Another thing we like to do is showcase what's possible with all the cool data science,
Isabella Velásquez: teams and tools that are out there, and so this is an example from another land that actually built a shiny APP and scaled it to hundreds of doctors in order to track coven cases and make decision making, based on that data information,
Isabella Velásquez: And then the other thing is providing thought leadership and providing a like I mentioned earlier opinions about a particular topic,
Isabella Velásquez: And so, RStudio does put these out as well, so, for example, our stance on interoperability between Python between and an R and then also things like the unique ways that code first data science can help companies and teams, be able to success successfully created a data science team,
Isabella Velásquez: And so, in addition to an external site, you should also consider an internal site for our blog for your team as well,
Isabella Velásquez: As this is an art enterprise Community meetup, this is actually the use case will be mostly focusing on today an internal blogs can help you,
Isabella Velásquez: share information between TEAM members in an easier and more efficient way I don't know if you've ever tried to find some advice that you're calling sent you over email,
Isabella Velásquez: It can be really hard to find and with a blog key information can be in one place will be searchable with tags, and so this to speed of communication,
Isabella Velásquez: Since everything's organized within the blog and services sort of Bulletin Board of ongoing projects news folks can search for information from the past but usually seeing what is the newest info,
Isabella Velásquez: And so generally gives your colleagues and opportunities to collaborate and share the knowledge if they know that there's a place that they can go to when they have something they want to share,
Isabella Velásquez: And with a consolidated place like a blog folks thoughts can be shared, very quickly, too many people rather than siloed in conversations or emails and others can learn about what their teammates are thinking about as well,
Isabella Velásquez: And so, ideally internal blog can foster Community that's open and inclusive and share the message that you all care about each other's work and your opinions and your experience,
Isabella Velásquez: On So there are a few differences between an internal blog and external blog you don't have to worry about things like keywords or search ability,
Isabella Velásquez: Your audience is confined to those in the organization, so you know exactly how to find them and the topics can be a little bit more flexible, rather than your company or your products like with an official corporate blog,
Isabella Velásquez: And there are many different types of posts that you can consider, for your blog as well, and this very much depends on your goals the sort of information that your team find useful,
Isabella Velásquez: However, let's say you want to create a blog for internal data science Community so topics for your community can include things like reflections from past projects how things went a summary of events any lessons learned and where to find the outputs, for example,
Isabella Velásquez: You could post things like virtual proposals to get feedback and feel and, of course, things like news and updates are very well suited to blog posts,
Isabella Velásquez: But, as you can see here there's many, many different types, that you can consider in terms of how to actually write the information that you want to share,
Isabella Velásquez: And then, besides these there's also the actual content,
Isabella Velásquez: And blog posts are a little bit about finding a sweet spot and service, so please,
Isabella Velásquez: and media like whether you are not fully text article images photos infographics videos on Center there's so many different ways of actually composing a blog post,
Isabella Velásquez: And you don't have to worry so much about optimization like I mentioned earlier, but you still want to make sure that your your content is engaging and useful and like I mentioned earlier, two blog posts can serve as a forum for discussion, if you have comments available on there,
Isabella Velásquez: But one thing I do want to mention is that a blog is not the place for absolutely everything, and so this is a framework that I find very helpful it's called the Di taxis framework and it,
Isabella Velásquez: tries to provide structure for technical documentation, so a successful technical team needs a mix of all of these tutorials how to use explanations and references,
Isabella Velásquez: And so it's always important to consider if you haven't blogged what what is the right place for a particular type of documentation, whether it should be stored somewhere else it's another location,
Isabella Velásquez: Or if it makes sense to write a blog post about it and then save it somewhere else, a little bit more permanently or,
Isabella Velásquez: write a blog post about something to raise awareness of a particular resource, so it helps people or point people to it for the future, but that is the one caveat that I want to mention now everything is seated for us inside the organization,
Isabella Velásquez: And so, in addition, like what else you need to consider if you want to write an internal blog,
Isabella Velásquez: I think first and foremost, is that, why do you want to create an internal blog and what are your goals and your ultimate purpose,
Isabella Velásquez: Are you hoping to get viewership for just your team or outside of your team or others at the organization and we hope that they're interested in the work as well,
Isabella Velásquez: Are you hoping that the blogs Facebook has about work projects, or is it more for an opportunity to learn more about the personal experiences of others,
Isabella Velásquez: And so having a clear goal can help you develop your blog what it looks like and help you explain to others it's going purposes as well,
Isabella Velásquez: and related to your goals, I think it's very important to illustrate the values that you want to instill,
Isabella Velásquez: So, if your blog is meant to be a place for inclusive it open this way to motivate your coworkers, then you want to make sure that the content of your blog demonstrates your values and that your colleagues are aware of these values as well,
Isabella Velásquez: And another thing to consider is again what would be helpful and relevant content, what do you want to share that your readers will actually want to read,
Isabella Velásquez: And for an internal data science Community what would be interesting enough to check in periodically at your blog to learn more for your teammates key to success is knowing what others find valuable and making sure that your blog reflects that information,
Isabella Velásquez: And like we mentioned before we don't want to blog to confuse others because of the other forms of documentation that already exist within an organization,
Isabella Velásquez: So it's important to know what's in an out of your blog and the tone style invoice that it will have and what sort of content are within the guardrail and separate blog and what is not,
Isabella Velásquez: Of course, as time goes on, and you learn things things may change, but having these in place can help you understand how you think you'll meet your goals and adapt accordingly,
Isabella Velásquez: and, ideally, you can get your colleagues involved in content creation as well this way you can showcase many different voices and perspectives and keep your blog updated with diverse ideas,
Isabella Velásquez: Of course, in this means your colleagues must be excited to be involved and share their own skill sets, and this can be done through direct invitations and, but it is helpful if you have for values and great content for your blog to help encourage collaboration,
Isabella Velásquez: And then another thing to note is that you want to get buy in for your blog not just from your teammates but also from your leadership team,
Isabella Velásquez: Since it takes time to create content, you might have to make the case that it's worth the time and effort it's not just you but also your colleagues to keep a frequently updated blog,
Isabella Velásquez: And this is done through the creation of valuable content work that makes it interesting useful and clickable to others and being able to communicate the value of that work to higher ups,
Isabella Velásquez: And with inviting folks to collaborate, you want to make sure that your blog reflects your values,
Isabella Velásquez: Okay, leave yes,
Isabella Velásquez: And so, if you like, if your blogs values are to be inclusive, you don't want to unintentionally exclude folks with the topics or the way that folks respond to discussions so getting consistent feedback and health,
Isabella Velásquez: can help determine whether your blog is truly benefiting your team and reflecting the values that you want to put in place,
Isabella Velásquez: and related to ownership, you want the blogs, be a part of the routine of your work, so that it doesn't feel like a big position or burden on you or others,
Isabella Velásquez: Perhaps your co workers have given a conference talk, or you just had a big strategy meeting you can blog posts just be part of workflow so that the blog has regular content but it's not,
Isabella Velásquez: His creation of a whole new thing, and if it's already somewhat integrated then it's a lot easier to keep the blog going,
Isabella Velásquez: And then, finally, there is the technical stuff too,
Isabella Velásquez: So there's the actual tools that you'll be using to build your blog and the training around those tools you don't want something like a blog to disappear when a particular person, you know who's another team, or something like that,
Isabella Velásquez: and, hopefully, you can build the skills across your team, the infrastructure cross your organization to keep it going,
Isabella Velásquez: And so to build a blog with R specifically you at least for the tools that I will mention say you will have to have some skills, like our mark down and make sure that it's not,
Isabella Velásquez: Just one person, but multiple people that has those skills in place, or at least a workflow to help those who are still learning aren't our markdown,
Isabella Velásquez: So that they are also able to contribute to the blog if they want to,
Isabella Velásquez: And while you don't need this is done, like github it's incredibly helpful to have,
Isabella Velásquez: version control can help resolve issues like a particular conflict is two people at the same file, at the same time, or something like that, and it can help keep track of changes,
Isabella Velásquez: And then, when they happen being able to revert it and things like that so highly recommend having version control in place,
Isabella Velásquez: And then, of course, you need a place to actually host your website and there are a few different options for if you're looking for a personal website, which will go through today if you're looking for a blog for your internal,
Isabella Velásquez: Company, then you will need to take other considerations it's a place like, if you want it behind,
Isabella Velásquez: Your servers so that it's secure or behind the password or on other protected hosting services that like notify or our CEO connects which again will quote through later,
Isabella Velásquez: So today's DEMO we're going to be talking about two different packages blog down is an our package that creates websites using our markdown and Hugo, which is a static website generator, and this is by default it actually can work on other with others site generators as well, like Jacqueline,
Isabella Velásquez: And distill for our markdown is a web publishing format optimized for scientific and technical communication and uses Panda, and that is still frameworks to create the websites and so will be taking a look at these two different packages and seeing what a blog looks like in both cases,
Isabella Velásquez: And in terms of how do you decide between bogged down or distill or a few factors, say, want to have a lot of flexibility and configure your website a lot and blog down would be the way to go,
Isabella Velásquez: Still, is a bit more minimal you can edit the theme and some colors but as we'll see bogged down, has a lot of variety in terms of things and can see a lot of options,
Isabella Velásquez: But there is, you know, a flip side to this with all that flexibility, it means that still is a lot more stable than bogged down,
Isabella Velásquez: Things like if the Hugo version or the theme changes and breaks, then you have to you know consider other options for your website and so very much depends on the direction that you want your blog to go,
Isabella Velásquez: So i'm going to stop sharing for one second and then move over to,
Isabella Velásquez: The other,
Isabella Velásquez: Can you see my screen,
Rachael Dempsey (she/her): Yes, I can see that he goes games,
Isabella Velásquez: Excellent great,
Isabella Velásquez: So these are,
Isabella Velásquez: The things that I mentioned, with the many, many different variety of,
Isabella Velásquez: options that you have, for your website,
Isabella Velásquez: And so my personal website is actually on lockdown are you created using block down a created,
Isabella Velásquez: With my co organizers website for our lady Seattle using this theme, and so this is available on the github repository that I shared in case you want to take a look at all the various scenes that are available on keto,
Isabella Velásquez: And so I did want to mention this one particular theme it's called kiva para and it is like it says here a Hugo theme you'll want to hang out with,
Isabella Velásquez: I created by allison Hill and our marketing team is a really, really great websites are less likely to consider if you are interested in creating a blog was blocked out,
Isabella Velásquez: And so, as you can see, it has this particular format and then, in addition to that, it has different layouts for the type of content that you might want to consider creating, and so this is what the blog setup looks like with different links showcase this way,
Isabella Velásquez: If you click into it, you can see me how it allows you to use a different are marked and features, for example, these different tab sets,
Isabella Velásquez: It also gives you a layout like this called projects where it's a little bit more static like I mentioned earlier, but could be well suited for a particular type of content that you want to share,
Isabella Velásquez: And just generally has like a lot of different capabilities and if you click into here,
Isabella Velásquez: In terms of what we talked about earlier, the consolidation of work this lets you take a talk link the website link the code have it all in one spot,
Isabella Velásquez: And so I created this DEMO site, if you are interested in creating an internal blog for for team or your organization or whatnot, but it could possibly look like using that hero kerosene, and so using some great content for Rachel Thank you Rachel,
Isabella Velásquez: here's some examples of what a series of blog posts could look like and so folks you know whether they're new to the team, or have been around for a while, can go in here, and you know, taken the great advice from their colleagues seven points,
Isabella Velásquez: In terms of resources, say you have a company theme or markdown template that you want to share and so, rather than having it kind of siloed and different file structures and things like that, having an easily findable spot on your blog,
Isabella Velásquez: can make it a lot easier for folks to you know find them use these themes, etc,
Isabella Velásquez: and, similarly, if there are different kinds of talks or sorts of competent and makes sense to,
Isabella Velásquez: To keep saved within your team for this institutional knowledge that you have the option for that as well, and so I just wanted to show a quick example of what this could look like,
Isabella Velásquez: Particularly if you are interested in cultivating,
Isabella Velásquez: Data science community with your team members,
Isabella Velásquez: And so now i'm going to move to an example of how to set up Hugo Apero and blogdown, and so this is on github,
Isabella Velásquez: and go into my repositories i'm going to start,
Isabella Velásquez: A project from scratch, however, I guess it's not fully from scratch, I would say that there are a few things that you will need to have already set up,
Isabella Velásquez: You will need R and RStudio, you need to have that now that you're RStudio needs to be connected with your github page as well, and so have If those are in place, then you can create a new repository for your website,
Isabella Velásquez: And so let's call it, you,
Isabella Velásquez: down,
Isabella Velásquez: we're going to initialize this were a readme file,
Isabella Velásquez: And then moving to RStudio we're going to file new project,
Isabella Velásquez: version control,
Isabella Velásquez: Git
Isabella Velásquez: Open this up,
Isabella Velásquez: So now we have a repository in RStudio idea that it's linked to our github page, and this is where folder and or the project in which we're going to create our bogged down website,
Isabella Velásquez: And so, if you go to file a,
Isabella Velásquez: I actually put this in the repository that I mentioned earlier, the snippet for actually creating a new website,
Isabella Velásquez: So down here and there, under blogdown resources getting started, and we are also assuming that you have blog down installed, as well as Hugo
Isabella Velásquez: And if you don't when you start the process, then it will prompt you to install the things that you need,
Isabella Velásquez: In addition, that website that I just mentioned, the Hugo Appero website, which is right here has amazing very detailed instructions on how to get set up using park down he go and he got pyro specifically so I already have flag down installed, so I can call them my library,
Isabella Velásquez: And then creating new sites, using the Hugo Apero theme,
Isabella Velásquez: Okay, so the new site is ready and actually asked me if I want to serve and preview the site i'm going to say yes, so that we can take a look,
Isabella Velásquez: This is a local version of our website, this is what we would be editing So this is the blank template from which you start your Hugo Apero theme and, as you can see, like we mentioned earlier, has at the blog option, the projects and the talks, etc,
Isabella Velásquez: And so i'm going to talk through a few of the files that are important to know so config.toml,
Isabella Velásquez: Is your site configuration and so, as you can see here there's already inputs available as the default like you would change things like the title to the title that you're interested in, for your particular website or your actual name, etc, the,
Isabella Velásquez: other thing I want to mention is Hugo Apero actually has a lot of built in themes and so, if we go here, it has this sort of coloring,
Isabella Velásquez: say that we want to use another sort of color so for us some more green so we would change it here, safe and if you can tell it actually changed the color by serving the site with once we save the file, so if we open this up looks a little bit different it's green now,
Isabella Velásquez: and change it one more time, just as an example, now we're going to change it from forest to violet and save, and now it says purplish color,
Isabella Velásquez: Another thing to mention is Hugo Apero also has built in bonds, so this kind of script that you see here, you can also change,
Isabella Velásquez: With some of the predefined responses that are already in place so say we want to change, Commissioner, to metropolis it's gonna that up,
Isabella Velásquez: And you can see that the font has changed as well um but like mentioned earlier, like the the websites built with,
Isabella Velásquez: R is actually very customizable and so you can actually you know, change the CSS to be very specific if it's square an internal data science team, and you want it to reflect,
Isabella Velásquez: The company's fonts and colors and you can do that as well, and so there are lots of different configurations that you can try, depending on what you are interested in,
Isabella Velásquez: And just to showcase what it looks like to change some information, so this is the front page,
Isabella Velásquez: And so within these folders are, I find it very useful and that there are like already,
Isabella Velásquez: texts and everything available because it's very easy to see you know if you make a change what exactly happens and,
Isabella Velásquez: It will also very much let you know if you made an error, as the site won't won't render,
Isabella Velásquez: And so, as you can see here the text here so sit down relax and get to know Hugo Apero, and that is actually,
Isabella Velásquez: configured through this file called underscore index.md in the content folder on so if we were to change that you can imagine, it would also change the front page of the website as well,
Isabella Velásquez: Welcome
Isabella Velásquez: let's see here, though, that block of text went away it now just says welcome,
Isabella Velásquez: Like like we yes it's,
Isabella Velásquez: just another thing to notice this blog has this particular look, but this can also be configured as well with the predefined,
Isabella Velásquez: Section options that if you go apparel has, and so, if you go to content and blogs, this is the particular blog and again index dot and deep,
Isabella Velásquez: scroll,
Isabella Velásquez: down,
Isabella Velásquez: So it says here a sidebar for your thoughts,
Isabella Velásquez: that's the title here,
Isabella Velásquez: We could change it here, by far, for your thoughts,
Isabella Velásquez: And then you can see, it has changed here, in addition, the Hugo Apero documentation is also showcase the different kinds of looks that you can go through, if you want to,
Isabella Velásquez: Really really change it up from the default,
Isabella Velásquez: So i'm going to commit all these changes let's say like your your site is ready to go you want it to you want to deploy deploy it and have it shareable with others because right now it's just sitting in your computer, you can say it was,
Isabella Velásquez: A message, but works and then push up to your repository,
Isabella Velásquez: So now we can see all the files have been included into our repository, and so one option for deploying your website is called network,
Isabella Velásquez: And it's actually what I use for my personal website, as you can see here and it makes it very easy, by integrating with github is ease of use github and, of course, a paid plan you can actually be password protected or or keep it private if it is something that you are considering for,
Isabella Velásquez: For your team on So if you go here just to show what it looks like to important a new project,
Isabella Velásquez: to connect with github,
Isabella Velásquez: Already authorized, and I call,
just making sure,
Isabella Velásquez: So you can see, I was testing things out,
Isabella Velásquez: Yes, new blog here and click it,
Isabella Velásquez: deploys faith,
Isabella Velásquez: And faith deploy in progress, and this should just take a couple of minutes, but then you will be able to share your website, using a URL similar to,
Isabella Velásquez: This one that I showed I showed you earlier, is also deployed on that, and you can change that URL you can add a custom one and there's our bind,io which a lot of folks use for their personal websites, and that is one option for you,
Isabella Velásquez: And so now we're going to go through the second tool that I mentioned, which is called still somebody to close this project,
Isabella Velásquez: So if you recall, for Hugo CARA we created a new github repository we clone that repository and through RStudio and then we use that script to create our blog,
Isabella Velásquez: Both the still and bogged down actually have an ad and then within into RStudio ID so i'm going to share what that looks like now,
Isabella Velásquez: So that means that this one won't be connected to to get home but, and you have seen what the process looks like and in that case so file project, and this is also assuming that you have the still already installed,
Isabella Velásquez: So directory and down here, you can see there's website using bogged down, and then there's also the still blog so we're going to click that and then you,
Isabella Velásquez: Still blog,
Isabella Velásquez: And you can change the title for it as well,
Isabella Velásquez: Create project going to go ahead and do that,
Isabella Velásquez: And so I have to admit I had not used to so and so preparing for this part for this presentation so it's very much new to me, but a just to showcase a few examples of what it looks like this is, this is still blog which is created using the stale and you can kind of see what the look,
Isabella Velásquez: You know the general look and it's very clean very, very fresh and very much well suited for scientific and writing, and so, if you go to the actual,
Isabella Velásquez: Still website,
Isabella Velásquez: You can see some of these different,
Isabella Velásquez: options that you have, for your scientific writing if you so choose so,
Isabella Velásquez: For example, if you have a lot of footnotes that this will show up in once you like hover over you're able to see you know, the text,
Isabella Velásquez: And things like citations are very readily available on just still so it's a great platform for this particular kind of writing,
Isabella Velásquez: And for folks who, just like you know the the look and feel of this particular blog and another resource that I haven't included in the resources is called the distillery and this gives you a lot more options in terms of customizing your distill site, if you so choose,
Isabella Velásquez: So, going back to RStudio we have our our distill side ready to go, you can actually see it if you go into this underscore site index dot html, and this is what the default looks like so you could see your blind to see your blog posts, etc, I,
Isabella Velásquez: slightly different than blog down, and if you want to create a post you post and we're going to do,
Isabella Velásquez: And so you can see here the sorts of configuration that you have, for your post terms of offer etc, and you can find it in our markdown script like you normally would and, if you want to see what it would actually look like on your website, you would click on it,
Isabella Velásquez: So now, you can see what your new posts look like, if you go back to your page, you can see, like a like a blog it's listed in order and and it's very straightforward in terms of creating a new post, and having a show up on your website,
Isabella Velásquez: i'm going to show a slightly different way of publishing your website specifically if you're interested in,
Isabella Velásquez: Keeping your website behind your firewall and our CEO connect as an enterprise product from RStudio and allows for publishing of things like shiny Apps,
Isabella Velásquez: dash Apps and many, many different things, including our markdown files and actually websites, creating artwork down as well,
Isabella Velásquez: And so I am going to show an example of what it looks like to publish a website, I actually have two accounts on RStudio or on connect, and so I need to specify which one I,
want,
Isabella Velásquez: And so, by taking this,
Isabella Velásquez: it deploys a website to RStudio,
This,
Isabella Velásquez: Is the point, though website now it's deployed successfully, this is what i'm going to show you in the beginning on, so this is our senior connects like I mentioned in an enterprise product from RStudio and so,
Isabella Velásquez: With it, you can also host these websites and if your company has RStudio connect the nice thing about this this it's behind the firewall,
Isabella Velásquez: And so you can specify specific folks to access your website, you can make it so that anybody on your art studio connect account can access the website, or you can open it up to absolutely anybody,
Isabella Velásquez: So I just wanted to really like quickly showcase this and what it looks like and say to have like a website behind a firewall on our RStudio connect,
Isabella Velásquez: But I wanted to just showcase the example of ours are under this still tool as well,
Isabella Velásquez: So with that that is all I have for today, again, please consider this an open call for, if you have a story about data science, please contribute or consider contributing to the data science,
Isabella Velásquez: or our seo blog we have samples like if you build an awesome package that you want to share with others,
Isabella Velásquez: And a also a post on like a particular tool that you've used and how you use inspired others and data science, so this is one we're showcasing our CEO cloud for teaching others data science,
Isabella Velásquez: And then also if you want just want to share your story and work together with me i'm happy to work with you, together on a blog post, and I would just love to hear from you, and so, with that I think it is time for questions Thank you so so much,
Rachael Dempsey (she/her): Thank you so much Isabella I see a lot of people asking for the links to your github to to use some of those examples, so thank you,
Rachael Dempsey (she/her): for putting that all there,
Rachael Dempsey (she/her): I can start reading some of the questions from slide Oh, but feel free to raise your hand to on zoom if you want to ask anything live as well,
Rachael Dempsey (she/her): So let me move over to slide oh,
Rachael Dempsey (she/her): And one of the questions was when deciding between using a Hugo framework or just still are we fixed with that choice, or is it easy to switch between both if you change your mind,
Isabella Velásquez: yeah i'd say as somebody who has switched their personal blog being a few times there are definitely some,
Isabella Velásquez: Some details that you need to take into account, for example, different themes might have a different setup for like that top part of the post,
Isabella Velásquez: And so it won't necessarily just work to say copy and paste all of your files over so I would say no you're not stuck with a particular theme, but you have to be aware of how you'd have to change things up, if you want to you know with to something you,
Rachael Dempsey (she/her): Thank you,
Rachael Dempsey (she/her): All who was send me and apologies if i'm pronouncing your name correctly, I see you have your hand raised if you'd like to ask that live,
Oluwafemi Oyedele: Yes, thank you very much,
Oluwafemi Oyedele: For a wonderful presentation on isn't blogged on package, but, like, for me, the concern is that, is there any way in which looking at, they will go up payroll team,
Oluwafemi Oyedele: You know, we have a contact page is there any way we can link it that contact page directly to our email without me using the forms pre packaged is a way I can go about that Thank you,
Isabella Velásquez: yeah I am actually not 100% sure having only use formspring before, but there is also, of course, like,
Isabella Velásquez: different options,
Isabella Velásquez: For contact forms, or you know linking,
and
Isabella Velásquez: If you want to share your email or things like that, but I would have to do a little bit of research and get back to you for more information,
Rachael Dempsey (she/her): Thanks Isabella and then, just a quick note for some of the questions in the chat if you just if you want to make sure that we don't miss them i'll put the slideshow link in there again as well just sometimes they get caught in between comments and I don't want to miss any of them,
Rachael Dempsey (she/her): But a rune I see you had a question, do we want to know html CSS html or those kind of things to get started with blog down and feel free to jump in and around if you want to add any other context,
Isabella Velásquez: When,
Rachael Dempsey (she/her): I think the question is this do you need to know html and CSS to get started,
Isabella Velásquez: I think, to get started,
Isabella Velásquez: I think the package has a lot of information and configuration to help you get started 16 notice some if we wanted to edit a particular post We just have to go in and,
Isabella Velásquez: change the text up, I would say, like knowing our and our markdown is more of a requirement if you're specifically hoping to to,
Isabella Velásquez: write a blog on using our markdown and, but of course html and CSS will help you configure your site a little bit more, and I would also say that our team has done amazing work in creating different sorts of,
Isabella Velásquez: packages and that helps you create more configuration, for your arm markdown new shiny Apps and things like that, without needing to know you know everything there is to know about CSS,
Isabella Velásquez: Actually, there is an art enterprise meetup that on business reports using our markdown that was incredibly helpful and kind of showcasing the different avenues for us for configuring you know these different types of content, without like having to know a ton of CSS,
Rachael Dempsey (she/her): I just put the YouTube link to that one too, if anyone wants to save it sorry it starts playing an ad the second you click,
Rachael Dempsey (she/her): There was another question, I see millie you had a question around, how do you change the URL and I know, there was a lot of great conversation happening in the chat as well millie would you want it jumped in and provide any context on that question,
Millie Symns: um yeah I think Alex helping us with that because i'm using block down the Hugo power with beam and i'm still like working on my local computer, but I was wondering how you end up changing the URL,
Millie Symns: So that yeah like reflects what you wanted to be in some of the strange I guess animal or whatever character that they give you,
Isabella Velásquez: yeah some of the names are very interested,
Isabella Velásquez: yeah we got the question was answered and,
Isabella Velásquez: feature to look at the chat later, at least, like, for my personal website he's the arbonne that I oh,
Isabella Velásquez: option that I mentioned earlier, I can find that how to do that and actually in the box down book as well and, and then, if you want a custom URL we've used,
Isabella Velásquez: Once did it using a cheap cheap Labor I think it's called a to,
Isabella Velásquez: To use a custom URL, but we did have to pay in that particular case this is where our lady Seattle,
Rachael Dempsey (she/her): Thank you, I know,
Rachael Dempsey (she/her): millie had another question earlier, too, I just wanted to make sure we didn't miss, but that was Isabel do you have any tips for content, writing to have the most impact for the audience,
Isabella Velásquez: I think i'm pretty sure there are some sort of,
Isabella Velásquez: Guidelines like you want to make sure that your title is catchy that it conveys like what you are going to display within the actual post itself, and there are like,
Isabella Velásquez: Some things that are like kind of known in that particular case like folks really like lists or how to use, and you can kind of,
Isabella Velásquez: Create your your work around that but I do think I really like it depends on what you are interested in and what your goals are like I mentioned earlier, that if if,
Isabella Velásquez: like somebody is searching for something like what do you want them to put into their search bar and be able to find like your post and consider it that way,
Isabella Velásquez: So that's for like the title in terms of like the content within the post, there are also some sort of some guidelines that folks day like you don't want a blog post it's too long, but you don't want wanted to short and things like that, but I think it's more about,
Isabella Velásquez: displaying like the the what you what you really want and sometimes you know is considering like Oh, maybe this can be a series of posts, as opposed to one particular pose,
Isabella Velásquez: Can you make it more engaging if it's for a personal post, maybe like adding these are you know finding images or things like that, if it's more,
Isabella Velásquez: Serious making sure that your headers are very clear that somebody you know quickly going through the barcodes can easily find the sections that they're interested in and things like that,
Rachael Dempsey (she/her): Thanks Isabella hey I see Larry you had your hand raised earlier which one ask your question live,
The new button,
Larry Lathrop: speech, the talk is there a way to connect to Google analytics to this coating to keep track of site visits or anything like that,
Isabella Velásquez: Yes, if,
Isabella Velásquez: You go to the configuration file that I showed you earlier there's actually a space there for Google analytics and so, once you have configured your Google analytics dashboard you put the,
Isabella Velásquez: The code or the idea that they give you in there and then automatically start feeding Google analytics information for your site,
Larry Lathrop: Oh Thank you so much,
Rachael Dempsey (she/her): I see one you had a question earlier if you're still on around the our markdown slides or if they were done with R markdown do you want to ask your question line,
Rachael Dempsey (she/her): The question was Isabella where your slides done with R markdown one really liked them and wanted to know how you made them, and if there was a tutorial also for some of the animations,
Isabella Velásquez: And it actually was not,
Isabella Velásquez: Our markdown it's called quarto and so created by RStudio team that link there and it creates presentations using reveal js and and it's actually integrated with R markdown and so because they can speak to each other, and so it yeah that's what I created the slides with,
Rachael Dempsey (she/her): cool I love those two,
Rachael Dempsey (she/her): I am checking slide oh I don't see any other questions there, let me go through the chat here and again feel free to raise your hand or even just unmute yourself and jump in with other questions to,
Rachael Dempsey (she/her): chanel is just asked what makes Porto different from our markdown,
Isabella Velásquez: quarto is built on,
Isabella Velásquez: Panda Doc and it,
Isabella Velásquez: Like our markdown can work on a variety of different,
Isabella Velásquez: With a variety of different languages and in a variety of different,
Isabella Velásquez: editors,
Isabella Velásquez: studio vs code etc um yeah I highly encourage looking at the website and checking it out and,
Rachael Dempsey (she/her): Thank you,
Rachael Dempsey (she/her): eugene I see had asked earlier how configurable is the site without learning go,
Isabella Velásquez: Well, well, I would say I don't want any go,
Isabella Velásquez: So I think it's quite configurable and so, for example, the hero apparel seen that I mentioned earlier, and it,
Isabella Velásquez: had to edit say, like the colors you can use the pre configured settings that they already have he wants to configure the fonts you can work in CSS or something called spss and,
Isabella Velásquez: You know, it makes it very straightforward in terms of like not having to know any go to to make your site look the way that you want it to,
Rachael Dempsey (she/her): Thank you so much as about I was just curious if other people on the call have,
Rachael Dempsey (she/her): built their own blogs, if you wanted to share them in the chat,
Rachael Dempsey (she/her): or also if anybody had built an internal blog for like their own company meetup and I would love to hear more about examples of that too,
Isabella Velásquez: awesome,
Rachael Dempsey (she/her): Thank you for sharing your blog there Jiwan,
Rachael Dempsey (she/her): Just scrolling through to see if there are any other questions to admin I see you just asked a question about the ideal length, do you want to jump in and I,
Rachael Dempsey (she/her): Also don't feel like anybody has to to jump in just trying to make us feel like we're in person, but the question was what would be the ideal length in terms of word count for blog posts let's say for an ETA post, where we present our analysis,
Isabella Velásquez: I think,
Isabella Velásquez: It can,
Isabella Velásquez: There are sorts of guidelines out there, I feel like for an ideal blog post, please let's say like,
Isabella Velásquez: 1000 words or something like that, but I would say to the blog, like many other things are great opportunity to try out sort of data analysis and data science skills,
Isabella Velásquez: So if you have the ability to ab test, you know trying out different things, with different groups of folks and seeing what seems to resonate the most I would also say like it very much depends too on the content that you're sharing like some things might just need a,
Isabella Velásquez: shorter version of of the blog posts versus some that go more in depth and so and there's also so many different things that you can tweak,
Isabella Velásquez: What they do post what time do you post and and things like that, and I think it's trying to understand your audience take a look at past data trying things out and seeing how what what ends up happening in order to really develop your blog strategy,
Rachael Dempsey (she/her): I see a few people asked about where to find the recording and so I do put them up to the studio YouTube we have a playlist of enterprise Community meetups it takes a few days, just to like edit it and work with R team to upload it so also just put the zoom recording,
Rachael Dempsey (she/her): In the meetup like details like for the actual event, right after this I can put that there it just won't be the edited version,
Rachael Dempsey (she/her): But also just was thinking, I may as well put in a little plug in and let people know that on Thursday, we also have another meetup,
Rachael Dempsey (she/her): on putting shiny into production and so that's a meetup with the Dutch National Institute for Public Health and you actually saw a little sneak preview of their APP in the blog post that Isabella shared,
Rachael Dempsey (she/her): So I will copy the link to that if you want to just add it to your calendar,
Rachael Dempsey (she/her): Are there any other questions or anything that I missed,
Rachael Dempsey (she/her): Oh Tony I see asked a question around blog frequency is once a month, a good frequency for blog posts,
Isabella Velásquez: i'd say,
Isabella Velásquez: I can depends, if you referring to your personal blog at least like for myself, I try to aim for once a quarter actually,
Isabella Velásquez: But I think you know that's that's for my own personal writing goals and for company blog it might be a little different you might want to be more continuously putting out content,
Isabella Velásquez: For example, we we aim for twice a week, and so I think it's again based on your goals what direction you want the blog to go to,
Isabella Velásquez: yeah like, ultimately, what are you looking for, are you looking for search ability within Google, are you looking for something else, and also what's feasible for for you and your team as well,
Rachael Dempsey (she/her): Thank you, is about, and I know you mentioned at the end, as well, that if people have ideas for blog posts or maybe like new packages that they've created and want to share that on the art studio blog,
Rachael Dempsey (she/her): That they can reach out to you, is it best through linkedin or Twitter, how should people connect,
Isabella Velásquez: yeah we would love,
Isabella Velásquez: to connect with you,
Isabella Velásquez: Even if it's not for a blog post would just love to chat and say hello, but yes, if you are interested, particularly in a blog post, I have my email on the slides feel free to reach out that way but linkedin Twitter on I check everything all the time, so we just love to hear from you,
Rachael Dempsey (she/her): perfect and then, if anyone ever has questions about anything may be mentioned in the meetups or about RStudio tools or anything like that you can always reach out to me too and,
Rachael Dempsey (she/her): i'll just put my email in the chat window to,
Rachael Dempsey (she/her): and the last thing I forgot to also share was if you'd ever like to speak at a meetup to or, if you have maybe an industry certain industry presentation, or you want to help get the Community together, I would love to help foster that,
Rachael Dempsey (she/her): And then, if you have other feedback for things you just like to see i'll put a few forms into the chat window right now to,
Rachael Dempsey (she/her): Isabella Do you see any questions that we missed,
Isabella Velásquez: But i'm very excited to look through,
Isabella Velásquez: everybody's website I,
Rachael Dempsey (she/her): Really,
appreciate it,
Rachael Dempsey (she/her): yeah it's so fun to see everybody's blogs share their to I know,
Rachael Dempsey (she/her): A great place that i've been able to find some of the blog posts is through our weekly bi curious how you stay up to date on other blogs to Isabella,
Isabella Velásquez: yeah our weekly definitely our bloggers another place, that I really liked the book,
Isabella Velásquez: And that the maintainer actually created a website for Python bloggers, which is also very useful and,
Isabella Velásquez: Just generally like social media whenever folks post things on linkedin or on Twitter if you'd like that's a huge help in terms of finding you know different resources,
Isabella Velásquez: and various community groups also help kind of aggregate different things so, for example, our ladies has started compiling all the different our ladies websites and so and and just generally useful to keep that a bookmark them and check it out whenever their updates,
Rachael Dempsey (she/her): awesome and so that example that you created, like the fake internal meetup group can people, so people can just take that and apply it to their own company if they wanted to like use it as a starting point,
Isabella Velásquez: yeah absolutely that's awesome my repository I can share it
Isabella Velásquez: So, like We walked through today can either start a new project with Hugo Apero or if you feel comfortable you know, taking this creating a clone and editing it to what you need that's another option as well,
Rachael Dempsey (she/her): perfect,
Rachael Dempsey (she/her): Well, there are no other questions Thank you so much Isabella for this walk through and all the resources, this was awesome and love this,
Isabella Velásquez: So thanks thanks grateful for the opportunity, and thank you all so much for for joining,